I'm Paul Kinlan developer advocate on
the chrome team and I'm working on
trying to make the mobile web platform
better for developers and trying to
educate people on how we think mobile
web development should be kind of done I
suppose I was gonna start this off by
saying that I think everyone in
California is a little bit too cheery
especially because of the sunny weather
and everything else so I decided to
bring all the wet weather with me from
London just so everyone kind of
experiences what it feels like to be me
so I suppose the first question everyone
has why mobile web UX a developer
conference and why someone like me is
talking about mobile web UX well are you
is used to have this impression of is
any wacky UX inter or UX designer or an
interaction designer okay ah be careful
I always used to think kind of UX or
interaction design was for people who
wore turtleneck sweaters and berries but
actually turned out that UX is like
critically important for everything that
we do when we're building applications
and if you're a developer and you're not
skilled in the arts of user experience
like me what do you do so it's
critically important as well for the
mobile context because I don't need to
tell you guys all about this but we know
mobile it's big right unit sales are
kind of skyrocketing okay there's an
existing desktop presence out there but
every single one of these devices that
gets old has a really capable mobile
browser on there and if you look at kind
of some of the work that the ads team
have been doing over the past couple of
months they've been doing research on
what people like about mobile what
people think about mobile websites and
pretty much everyone likes a mobile
based experience they hate desktop
experiences on the web so we know
Mobile's huge and if we're developers we
like how do we deal with this context
where we need to define and build for
the mobile web well if you look at kind
of the way mobile native is going
they're kind of really pushing forwards
on what it means to be a native
developer and a native kind of UX or
native experiences and they're trying to
push forward these kind of different
interaction styles so we have obviously
voice interaction that's a big thing on
native platforms now whether it's Google
now or Siri and these types of things we
also have kind of card based interfaces
and gestures and
and all these really things which like
all these things that didn't really
exist maybe one two years ago and if you
compare that to the web we are actually
doing pretty well on the web at the
moment in the sense of we are starting
to get some great mobile based
experiences out there we've got
forecasts the BBC Yahoo everyone is
building these kind of everyone who
knows and gets that mobile that's
critical is starting to build mobile
based experiences but they're not as
kind of they don't take advantage of as
much of the kind of the hardware
capabilities and interaction patterns
that native applications are starting to
do so my talk was going to be about how
we could bridge that gap by how we could
start to use voice interactions how we
could start you swipe gestures and card
based interfaces but I looked at like
the well the top thousand sites
originally and I was trying to assess
like what the common patterns are what
the mobile nosov the sites are and it
was actually really startling we found
some really kind of interest in things
where 53% of sites still had a desktop
experience and these are the top
thousand sites right this is like the
head of the mobile web is still desktop
right there's a couple of really great
examples Wikipedia and Google Yahoo and
a bunch of others that get mobile but
everyone else in the mobile web is kind
of sucks
right they don't actually seem to think
that the mobile web is actually
important and this desktop experience is
actually pretty bad because basically
the browser way of the browser works is
it goes well we know you've got a
desktop web the web is for desktops at
the moment so we're going to have to
scale everything down to fit on a mobile
device and if you look at some of the
stats where from Nazi and I'll try and
share a link later on where users like
70 basic guy seventy six percent of
users prefer optimized mobile
experiences this was a survey of a
thousand users at the time and no one is
really catering for that at all in the
mobile web we also find that 25% of
sites even regardless of whether they
were mobile optimized or not their
content didn't fit in the mobile
viewport and this is an example of site
where basically you could scroll around
the site you couldn't zoom out from that
view it was terrible you can't zoom out
you have to pan around the user
interface just to read some text it's
not a great user experience and it's
quite common in the top 1,000 sites and
we found that a whole bunch of
developers I think it was actually 65%
of user sorry hated the fact that they
have to scroll around the content to
actually find me a piece of information
that they want to find
and then we found that 83% of sites had
hard to touch areas on the screen now
quite a lot of these sites were just
like maybe one or two little buttons
were kind of quite small but then you
get sites like I can use which I know a
lot of people read and love and I
actually love it as well but it's
completely not optimized for the mobile
experience and then when you actually
try and click on link the browser is a
really hard time trying to figure out
what you actually meant to click on and
this is this is actually a really hard
problem to solve at the moment well on a
desktop type of experience but you when
you build in mobile experiences it gets
a little bit easier and this is my blog
from ages ago it's horrible and if you
can see I'm not a graphics designer or
an interaction design or anything but
basically are the top 1,000 sites 60
percent of them had readability issues
and this actually comes from the fact
that if you're not developing a desktop
site and the site has toward not
developing a mobile site and the site
has to get squished down onto the mobile
device without zooming in you you have a
real hard time actually reading and
reading the text and if you see from
this screenshot actually what's Chrome's
tried to do is try to be clever and
actually boost the font size as well
using the text auto-sizing that greg
talked about earlier on and I'm going to
kind of briefly talk about that later on
but basically text is not readable on
the mobile web at the moment it seems
and 10% of sites and the top 1,000 sites
still used plugins plugins that don't
work on the mobile web flash jar
Java applets Silverlight you know you
need unity3d all these things where
we've been building kind of rich
Internet applications and they've been
able to do some great stuff for us but
people are still actually have this
deployed on them on the modern mobile
web so actually this is my first ever
kind of mini product announcement we're
trying to build a tool that helps you
identify and understand the problems
that you would have as a web developer
and this tool is kind of the toolless
kind of focused towards more of the the
developers are not naturally interaction
designers just help you identify all
those issues that we talked about before
so I know Brian mentioned PageSpeed
insights a couple of minutes ago where
it analyzed your kind of your network
performance of your site in the context
of mobile well we're extending this
further today and it's it's in the test
version at the moment you're the first
guys to actually see this but we extend
in PageSpeed insights to also do user
experience analysis and we're trying to
get the fundamentals correct we're not
trying to say hey
your navigation is kind of busted your
off-screen menus and all these types of
things don't work we're trying to make
sure you actually get the fundamentals
correct and I'm going to go through a
quick demo with this in a minute but
basically this tool finds or lowers your
site in a mobile context and then
analyzed it to check for the viewport
the viewport content size whether the
text is actually readable whether the
links and buttons and other areas are
clickable and it identifiers the uses of
legacy plugins now this is very kind of
early stage and we really really really
want your feedback on this tool whether
you think some of the insights are a
little bit too harsh or critical and
other types of things that you as a kind
of developers can understand which like
features that we could assess
programmatically by just analyzing the
page so I'm going to give you a quick
demo I will say if you if you bump on UX
equals one at the end of PageSpeed
insights you'll be able to go and test
this today on your own sites I'm just
going to go and analyze the site which I
know is terrible and fails every single
URL or every single test it's exactly in
my site so I was like I was actually
looking for sites to go and I was like I
just you know I'll try my old site from
like 2000 and 2010 yeah and it failed
everything it was terrible
but anyway as you can see here we've got
the kind of the mobile site this is the
render view from a headless webkit it's
got all the speed criteria that Brian
talked about before to help you build
better mobile network like network
performance but it's also got this whole
area for user experience and what it
tries to do is say hey we've rendered
the page we've looked at what the
content looks like and we're gonna tell
you the areas where we think you should
improve and if you've got a purely
desktop experience quite often it tells
you you need to prove everything but if
you improve everything but if you've got
a mobile based experience the number of
criteria then checks that it kind of
fails on gets a lot smaller um the first
is legible text this is kind of cool so
it basically identifies every single
piece of text on the web page not just a
zoom in a little bit which doesn't
render clearly meets doesn't meet the
minimum kind of say 12-point style font
size now this is kind of cool so I've
got a whole lot of things I used to work
for switch media so that's coming use to
work out let's have a look my dad's
cycling blog okay so you can click on a
link
and it highlights it inside the user
interface exactly where the I'd like the
identified problem is this is really
cool because if you're trying to find
different areas of the text on your page
which you've got problems then you can
actually kind of identify that pretty
quickly
the really nice thing and it's it's kind
of I think it's there in the API but
there's an API back-end to this which
you can actually programmatically run
through your own workflow tools which
you could then use against your site
which would analyze UX problems across
your site automatically so it's pretty
cool like we can find all these
different areas where everything kind of
fails and because it's a desktop site
you can see pretty much everything is a
little bit rubbish it tells you kind of
roughly how tall it is on the screen at
that time so that the legible text the
other thing is touch targets so we
identify all the areas on the page where
there's potential for confusion by the
browser or the user into what would be
clicked essentially so in many cases
obviously it's links and its links
inside text for instance but it's also
input elements form inputs everything
that is basically has a click event
which you can listen to it will identify
look out and inspect to see whether it's
correctly sized so as you can see here
the search box on this page is it's too
small it's actually I don't know what
there was a oh there we go do it again
it's actually identified the fact that
it's and this is white Peter at the
moment so we look at this radio box
it's 714 micrometers on a typical device
I don't know what web developers going
to do with that but all we know is it's
really small but we've got all these
other areas here where we're trying to
identify all these kind of potential
touch targets which could be missclicked
but that's not all there's also this
area here at the bottom which identifies
targets which actually need additional
space in because the way that the
browser's work is they try and do
something you like the clicks and the
areas that were the brow or the user is
clicking on the page and if there are
two elements which are kind of pretty
close or potentially overlapping then
that creates the potential for confusion
for users and one of the things that
we're doing here is we're trying to
identify the top of the tap targets
which would potentially be too close and
overlap and actually provide potentially
the wrong action for the user and then
there's some of the basic things as well
sighs the content for the viewport as
you can see here like
everything is sized incorrectly but what
this is trying to say is that this is
the critical area here but the actual
physical size of the page is one
thousand two hundred and ninety nine CSS
pixels and if you've ever done any
mobile web development before you'll
know that the actual default size of the
browser is 980 pixels or 960 pixels or
not 980 sorry what this basically means
is if the content busts outside the
viewport is too big for the viewport
rather than scale it down further it
forces the user to have to pan and
scroll around the site so we're trying
to identify areas where you know on the
page there you've got air you've got
content on the page which will cause
that now like the page to bust out the
side of the mobile device in theory at
least and then we have the configured
viewport now this is a relatively simple
test if you haven't got a viewport it'll
tell you you haven't got a viewport if
you haven't got a viewport and then you
just drop on into your site you're not
gonna have a good time so you're gonna
have to think about actually building a
mobile experience which I'm gonna try
and talk about for the rest of this this
talk now so this is PageSpeed insights
this is one of the things that we really
want you to kind of go out play with
give us a whole bunch of feedback about
whether you think this is like these
checks are actually good for you whether
they actually work on your site as well
because we found instances where there's
bugs for like tap target menus across
the top just don't work very well but we
want as much feedback as possible and if
you go to that page as a feedback link
right the bottom so this talk really is
about mobile web UX building blocks
getting the basics right so that we can
build really compelling experiences on
the top in the future whether that's
with polymer kind of web components and
a whole other other stuff we want to get
to the point where you don't have to
worry about everything that was the
PageSpeed tool essentially is checking
for so I've split this into two
different sections display and
interactions and how they relate to the
kind of the PageSpeed insights insights
tool display is about kind of how the
content is presented on the device and
obviously interaction is about how the
user kind of manipulates the screen and
manipulates all the content whether it's
a signup form whether it's like a
payment button and those types of things
because if users can't interact with
your site they don't buy things they
can't login they can't sign up for your
service
and you have a really bad time on mobile
so we look at display and I'm going to
go through this pretty quickly and I
really hate doing this slide but the
most important and critical thing that
you can do for building a mobile web
experience is make sure that you use it
viewport the viewport defines
essentially the size the content should
be on that area on the screen and this
is our preferred recommended
configuration meta viewport meta
viewport or meta name equals we brought
content width equals device width
because that essentially allows you to
ensure that everything size - whether
it's 320 pixels an iPhone
up to about 380 on the nexus 4 and it
basically means the browser doesn't have
to scale the content down from a
traditional desktop experience into a
more mobile experience and I think
that's a bug in chrome at the top we'll
get from there and actually the reason
why I want to show you why this is
actually kind of kind of critical is
that I've taken the like the the way
that the browser renders content on a on
a like a desktop content on the mobile
device and compared it to how its
rendered on a viewport configured page
and as you can see on the right it's
probably little bit hard for you guys to
see but that's a 12-point font which
means a kind of arm's distance it looks
like a 12-point font on a page
essentially a normal piece of paper if
you don't have a viewport it roughly
reads like a five-point font like it
looks like the point where it's nearly
kind of unreadable okay we have retina
based devices which letters kind of
distinguish layer on the text a little
bit better but five points is really not
that readable Nexus 5 is the same
everything is roughly a third of the
size of what it's actually intended to
be so a 12-point font in this case reads
like a four point font Nexus 7 obviously
is better bigger screen and all the type
of things but it's getting to the point
where the text on a default mobile
experience or desktop experience on a
mobile device it's completely unreadable
seven points is just at the point of
being unreadable
and obviously the Nexus 10 and the kind
of the iPads as well it's a lot less
noticeable having not having a viewport
you get to the point where the text
looks like a nine point one kind of
whatever I told you then was really a
lie because basically browsers try to
compensate for the fact that they know
that the desktop web is terrible on a
mobile device so in Chrome's case we use
kind of text auto size and basically
what happens is when the page just as
the page loads an algorithm goes through
all the kind of the text nodes and look
to see what text is
should resize to make more visible and
on some pages like my blog before it's
not too bad the content at the top of
the page is made bigger because that's
the primary focus but then you get to
sites like this which is hacking news
which is the same page as we saw before
there's certain comments which read
really well like the browser's gone yeah
this looks important it's not semantic
analysis it's just kind of some basic
basic heuristic but then there's other
bits like in the middle here which you
can't so you can't read the text you
can't be the text here you can't read
the text on the device you have to zoom
in so the algorithm isn't perfect and
the best way to get around that is to
start the design for a mobile web based
experience obviously use a viewport
there are little hacks to kind of get
around it like by making sure you can't
end things over a hundred thousand
pixels high it's not even worth going
there because that's just one of those
things which might change in the future
when people kind of get rid of that but
essentially browsers try to compensate
and when the browser tries to compensate
it kind of starts to ruin your design
essentially it doesn't represent how you
actually intended the user to read your
content and obviously fit the content of
the viewport there's not actually
anything technical that we can say about
this is just make sure everything is
sized correctly and there's no kind of
horizontal scrolling vertical scrolling
is fine and horizontal scrolling is
actually fine by default but if you have
to have the user pan in multiple
directions
that's when users actually start to get
frustrated and I'll share the link later
on where the ads team have done this
analysis to actually show that users
don't like it but the interesting thing
is that scrolling varies from platform
to platform and iOS at one point I think
it probably still does you have a scroll
lock so if you're kind of moving up in
the vertical orientation you can't
scroll after right at the same time
because it's saying well you know you
don't want to pan around you want to
just look at the content itself we want
to get in this situation away from the
situation where you have to actually
move around the web like that I'd have a
question who's got a 24 inch phone no oh
okay that was really heavy by the way
it's crazy so I'm not gonna tell
everyone about this too much like media
queries we should be kind of
concentrating on like mobile first
design responsive design as well
obviously you can kind of orient like
you can design your site to work better
on portrait and landscape and whole load
of other stuff this is one of those
areas that's like super critical for web
development you know you want to be
looking at how
you actually design your site to be
responsive rather than have to do it all
in the server it's best to do it on the
client I'm not going to go into it too
much because it's I am pretty sure
everyone knows about this the thing I
want to do say is about how you decide
the breakpoints in your site and Paul
Lewis has been working on a redesign for
html5 rocks which is our documentation
resource and the old site looks cool the
new site looks cool but what happened is
we on the original site on the Left we
basically try to size four devices so
every other week we would look at kind
of Google Analytics to understand the
the different types of devices that were
available or kind of accessing our
content and whether it was a tablet
device or whether it was a mobile device
and then we would say well this kind of
looks like a tablet size we'll push them
to the tablet user interface looks like
a desktop will push them to the desktop
interface and what we found but rather
than actually concentrating on the
devices whether it's iPhone and Android
or whatever and the device form factors
we literally just tried to say that well
actually will scale the content out left
and right and will decide where the
breakpoints are based off how the
content looks at that individual time so
basically saying you size the the
breakpoints to the content rather than
the actual devices which a lot of people
do and we were just as guilty as doing
that as everyone else the reason why we
say this is because we went from 17
media queries our media queries for the
HBO filerock site if you go and check it
now is just an absolute mess and it's
really hard to maintain and you get into
this weird situation when it doesn't
actually we've got a weird overlap in
media queries it doesn't actually kind
of know what interface it's supposed to
present to users at any one time so we
went from 17 media queries down to
something which is a lot more manageable
for us for and we have a nice-looking
kind of content on desktop mobile and
tablet as well one of the other areas
that we're kind of talking about is font
readability and I looked at the human
interface guidelines and this is the
whole kind of the PageSpeed insights
test the legibility test and human
interface guidelines from Apple is
really cool because they say you just
can't read your text or the word in your
app it doesn't matter how beautiful your
typography is and this kind of is it's
ultimately applicable regardless of
whether you're designing paper-based
content or kind of web-based content or
or content inside apps and our
guidelines and the way that the
PageSpeed insights tool works is it
tries to say you should be sizing your
text to be
readable kind of arm's distance which
from like numerous studies whether it's
Apple Microsoft or Google as well a
12-point fonts is is the minimum that
you want to suggest which is roughly 1m
or roughly 16 pixels in height but the
interesting thing as well is that we
actually is trying to say that what you
should be doing as well is like consider
where the user actually uses your
content they might be out in the cab or
walking down the street and you want to
make sure that there's a decent amount
of contrast between the foreground tech
color and the background color as well
we don't actually analyze that yet and
we're trying to work out whether like
these type of things are important and
not for for you as a mobile web
developer when you're checking your site
and obviously things like maintain
decent line Heights so that the text is
readable and you don't have to get
confused between the lines yeah so font
readability is kind of critical that's
one of the things that we look for when
we're doing the PageSpeed insights tool
we also want to kind of we don't check
for this but we're trying to get people
to limit the use of web fonts at the
moment especially on a mobile device
because if the web font doesn't exist
either in the cache or on the user's
device then essentially especially on
webkit-based browsers and blink based
browsers you're left waiting around for
the content to actually appear because
the font doesn't exist so it's not
actually kind of it doesn't actually
appear on the site at the time and our
guidance at the moment and this might
change once the browser implementations
change essentially it's just to use it
for headings but critical content like
the text like if it's html5 rocks the
article body content would just be a
normal system-wide font essentially the
interesting thing to say is Paul Irish
had a post on Google+ talking about the
flight the flash of unstyled text
essentially where we're talking about
the different implementations between
browsers so obviously WebKit and blink
are kind of quite consistent because
they're both up the same heritage where
the content doesn't appear whereas
Firefox is a little bit different
I believe the text appears as a system
font essentially until the actual web
font is downloaded and we're looking for
kind of your feedback about what you
think is the most important thing
because we want to make sure that if
we're going to be if we want to be good
web citizens and everyone wants to get
this we have the same type of
implementation across browsers and it
might be at some point that the actual
Firefox implementation is the preferred
one but obviously we need a lot of
feedback from developers so go to that
post have a look at kind of the
suggestions and then let Paul
and everyone else know how you want the
how you want to have web fonts presented
to the user I'll tweet this link how
because I know it's not exactly visible
so let's display I want to talk about
interactions and I'm going to be really
quick click this ambiguous on is really
important because essentially the user
like this is Chrome when the user clicks
on an area inside Chrome and it doesn't
know exactly where the user is it
presents a magnifying glass it's a great
accessibility feature the problem is
though that it actually presents a
challenge to users because it's an extra
step before they actually do anything so
we want you as a developer to try and
get away from that and I'm gonna kind of
roughly go through the process for this
how this actual disambiguation works
essentially you use a clicks on the
screen it's roughly a 48 pixel bounding
box works that where the click is ads in
an area kind of been like an arrow
buffer around the side finds all the
targets inside the bounding box the
potential candidates for what the user
actually meant to click scores each
element based on the closeness to the
original touch in this case finds one
that's the closer to it like that's the
closest element and then it basically
compares the scores across all the rest
of the elements and then tries to find
the elements where the distance between
the original touches roughly roughly
about half the distance to the closest
element relatively complex the code if
you're interested in CAI chrome is over
there the simplest things answer is just
use sensible padding like you're
building you build a site just don't be
stupid like space elements out pretty
quickly which leads us on this whole
idea about what are kind of interesting
tap targets all the different types of
human interface guidelines talk about
things which aren't native to the web
points obviously for fonts but dips and
Android like what a dip
I could Microsoft to 9 millimeters I
don't know how that really applies to
the web but roughly if you take one CSS
pixel the standard reference to be 96th
of an inch you can roughly work out that
everything is around between 29 and 33
pixels in size our recommendation in the
tool that we use at the moment is around
twenty six pixels but with a decent
amount of padding we recommend in eighth
CSS pixels or roughly about two
millimeters worth of padding and that
helps the disambiguate and not have to
reselect which or kind of basically pop
up the other interesting thing around
this as well is that if you're trying to
end get data put into your system
interaction you get used to sign up to
your app or your site you want to have
form inputs that are easy to read and
easy to enter date
labels are the thing you should always
go for this basically the reason why
labels are actually important is because
in this case it's doubling the amount of
touch size that is available for the
user to actually be able to focus the
input element now obviously you can
style your site however you want but in
this case here like I've got the the top
element and the bottom element both are
touchable and both focus the same input
box as well so it's it's relatively
simple obviously it's up to you how you
actually decide how its styled but it's
one nice little thing that I quite like
who actually likes waiting in the queue
I mean I'm British I do I love waiting
here's like this is me trying to get to
Berlin I patiently waited in this key
for three hours without complaining at
all to anyone and then I got to the
front and I apologize for missing my
flight and like it wasn't me mister
anyway it's kind of like wait and
300-millisecond click delay right the
300-millisecond click delay is this
thing to help us kind of oops sorry like
get to get the user to zoom into the
content for a desktop it's type display
now it slows down interactions everyone
knows it's horrible
we don't really complain too much it'd
be great if we could kind of remove that
from the web I do have a kind of a
question though and this is styled off
the Google interview questions which we
know are great at hiring candidates how
much time do we waste every day with the
300-millisecond click delay has anyone
got a guess right I I have no idea right
that's what everyone says when they ask
to get asked these stupid questions
right no idea what a stupid question but
actually I do know for Wikipedia right
Wikipedia actually publish all their
mobile traffic they get roughly about
three billion requests today on mobile
which 1400 correct requests per second
which is 423 wasted seconds every second
just on Wikipedia alone which roughly
equates to one year wasted every day
just waiting around for your click to
complete so it's pretty cool chrome is
removing the 300-millisecond click delay
which is great news and I'm gonna talk
about what we're gonna do but it's not
gonna be for everyone and it's great for
links I don't know whether this actually
came across very well it looks like the
videos on playing properly you click on
a link you don't have to wait 300
milliseconds but I
you saw before like if it takes ten
seconds to load your page the 300
millisecond salient you get is not
you've got bigger fish to fry
essentially of your network requests or
that slow but it's great for
interactions and Jake are all made this
video on the left is the 300-millisecond
click delay on the right it's a zero
milliseconds away everything just feels
a lot more responsive like you click on
the button or checkbox or a late on and
on this get a link you click anything
that has a click handler it happens
straight away just feels a lot more
natural and reactive so how would you go
about removing the 300-millisecond click
delay it's not killed for everything
it's simple answer and it's very relates
to one of the very first slides use a
viewport make sure the width equals
device width but also size the contents
of the viewport if we don't have to pan
left and right then we've got a really
strong indication of the fact that the
user will not have to zoom in to the
page so that if we don't have to zoom in
why actually do the DoubleTap to click
gesture pinch to zoom is still work but
double-click tap to click we don't
really need or use fast click I know
some of the FT labs guys are here today
if you're not in chrome you can use the
fast click library to kind of kind of
get around some of those interaction
problems who loves typing on the phone
yeah good because no one loves typing on
the phone at all the goal that we want
to try and get developers to is just to
minimize the amount of type and that you
have to force your users through
obviously this is really simple I hate
talking about this slide because it's
been around for years
it's just they take advantage of
specialized keyboards and mobile devices
like if it's an email address say it's
type email you'll get an @ sign if it's
like a beta or so if it's a telephone
number say the telephone number you get
a special dial pad if it's number you
get a special number pad if it's a date
you get a special data entry a date data
entry button now it doesn't speed up the
like speed up the like the time to
actually complete a form but it does
increase the accuracy and I did some non
completely non scientific tests so I'm
obviously a good authority on this and
some of the tests that I did where I
asked people to enter certain kind of
input like like certain kind of data
basically was like nineteen ninety-five
percent accuracy at the time for the
input types because it was so
constrained now that's completely
unscientific so don't go about quote in
that one but everyone knows when they
see the correct input type they like it
also take advantage of autocomplete the
browser's are actually pretty good at
this
and if you look at Stack Overflow
everyone seems to hate it but you want
to try and get your users not entering
data if it's already stored inside the
browser and the way that you get
autocomplete to work is to use kind of
names for field labels that are similar
or like are that well-known essentially
so if you want to get the first name F
name he's gonna in the surname L name
email address obviously name equals
email those type of things they just
help the user if it kind of auto starts
autocomplete you press it the forms
completed really quickly and it's zero
cost for you as a developer to actually
implement the next is
requestautocomplete so who's heard of
requestautocomplete a couple of people
look really cool basically the idea
behind this is to have a programmatic
access to the author like the form
autocomplete now this is another video
by Jake it's a really good video demo by
Jake essentially you have an API which
uses an existing form you call you can
basically go I want to check see if
requestautocomplete exists if it doesn't
you present the original form so that
people can just go straight through and
enter the dates or in if it does exist
you can call the requestautocomplete
which pops up the box that we saw before
let's the user select kind of their data
maybe also if you're in the US can have
autocomplete the credit card with Google
Wallet and then you can go through and
complete the form and submit really
quickly it's yeah the aim is to kind of
really improve the kind of the time to
submission perform data if you have to
enter this manually it's like two
minutes just enter in text to kind of
get your shipping address and billing
address and a whole lot of other stuff
and we want to get away from that so the
request autocomplete API is there I'm
going to start wrapping up now our goal
is to get as much feedback at the moment
for this tool so please go out and check
the PageSpeed insights tool put UX
equals one at the end and you'll get to
start to get the actual the tools
available and I'd like to thank everyone
I know of run over a little bit mobile
UX that appspot.com is these slides
html5 Rockstar come forward slash Mobile
is our mobile documentation entry point
thank you
you